brad keller the royal starter has
sufficient motivation off to a very
tough start and facing a tough lineup
fletcher ohtani and trout will be the
first three angels to go against keller
all those pitches inside and then keller
gets in with a fastball up and away
keller if he continues to attack like
that and go at these guys with some good
quality pitches
he's going to get back on beam which
gets us to mike trout who struck out
four times last night
jammed him
and it's a long run in for taylor and
for a moment there looked like he was
going to give way to whit
but realized it was his play and there
are two outs
and solaire falls forward to make the
catch
so he's in the game and brad keller has
his first
scoreless first inning griffin canning
is on the mound for the halos alone
start this year it was at toronto
you almost have to look past those four
runs because that was late he did strike
out seven pitching into the sixth inning
ben attendee goes after the first pitch
and that's into right field walsh is
there and ben attendee
is on with a one-out single so he's hit
safely in
eight of the ten games
ben attendee runs and the throw is in on
a hop and now into center field
and ben and tendy will be at third with
one out
[Applause]
over the mound
fletcher charges
and solaire
was that off of his foot nope catcher's
interference
he looked down at solaire
and it appeared that he just gave up
and didn't run it out but he felt the
bat hit ben boom's glove and it was not
called immediately but dj rayburn said
catcher's interference you can see it
everybody runs and taylor swings and oh
no he hit
carlos santana oh that hurt so that is
an out and hopefully santana isn't out
oh man
he scalded that ball
[Applause]
very high to left field into the sun and
ben attendee puts his hand now his glove
and he finds it and makes the play
that's hit well left center field and
ben and tendy is there so and he didn't
have very far to go so the royals were
playing him in the right spot
jammed and it's going to be caught by
nikki lopez
that is an eight pitch
one two three second inning for keller
go ahead
a ground ball base hit a little squib
infield single and now a walk and the
bases are loaded for mike trout
chased again
so trout has struck out
in five of his last six at bats and that
is a huge out for brad keller
great sequence of pitching there and
that's what i'm saying not throwing he's
pitching
got him with a fastball at 97.
so with the bases loaded and one out
keller strikes out trout and walsh way
to pick up wit
[Music]
andrew benintendi leads things off
griffin down and in that's a great
sequence a really good sequence but
griffin cannon change up change up
fastball down and in slider gets ben
attending tight
sharp good spin
on the breaker ball salvi
was a big out for canning and getting
out of the first inning
when he took a called third strike
that is well hit into deep right center
field trout is back and that is gone
and salvador perez
has his seventh hit of the series
he is seven for 10. wow
all aboard
get on salvi's back because he's
carrying the load man i'll tell you
inside out little help with a breeze
blowing that way once he got it airborne
you knew it was not coming back what a
nice compact swing middle
middle and he kept his hands inside the
baseball great balance there man that's
a picturesque swing and follow through a
royals fan ends up with the home run
ball but hey young guy
hope you enjoyed your trip to kansas
city
two strike delivery that one is chased
and missed
and a strikeout victim is carlos santana
so it's kind of been an
all-or-nothing inning for the royals
three batters of batted two have struck
out but one is hit a homer and now with
two away here's solaire
there's a two-strike delivery that's
chased and missed by solaire so the
inning ends on a strikeout they sent
four to the plate three of them struck
out one hit a homer we're headed to the
fourth inning it's one nothing kansas
city
that one was out over the plate that is
a fair ball inside the bag and taylor's
got an infield single he thought about
advancing taylor runs
he got a pretty good break and he is
going to be
in there he kept his foot on the back
and taylor's at second with nobody out
dozier not only hits it to right he hits
it to deep right
so taylor will move up 90 feet so that
is a quality at bat for dozier
swinging
shallow center
and fletcher is out and he makes the
play
taylor tags and he's gonna be in there
outstanding how about the skills of the
royals able to score on a 110 foot sack
fly that's what taylor good job he read
it he went back to third saying i can
score on that and once he catches it if
he does his momentum is carrying him so
far fletcher he can't stop and turn
around and make a good throw home so
that's a heads up
rbi for for cam but also taylor getting
it for him that is big right there just
talked about his instincts on the bases
and we saw a whole bunch of it right
there
fantastic work
here is mike trout
he lines that one into center field for
a base hit two into the count there's a
shot down the line it's not a homer but
it is extra basis
the halos
will send the runner on around to the
plate here he comes it gets away
an aggressive piece of base running for
mike trout all the way from first base
yeah when i was watching trouty rounding
the base at second base i thought he was
thinking scoring on that one dice did a
nice job of getting that baseball
getting in quickly there's that hanging
breaking ball it wasn't a home run but
it was a rocket double for walsh down in
the corner and trout he's looking trick
picking up brian butterfield and he's
saying he's going he's going to take
that shot it's been a tough time trying
to score low throw trout able to get in
there
i love that aggressive base run that
goes back to what we talked about the
first game of the series and trotty had
to go back and tag the play because he
didn't tag it at that moment
now perez up
salvi hits it hard again
that's his eighth hit of the series
here comes witt around third
salvi's into second and the royals lead
3-1 salvador perez he's reaching lava
hot status carrying the royals scoring
with from first base on a screaming mimi
that ball was screaming off the bat
what kind of
solid contact on the young reliever we
talked about is kid chris rodriguez with
a firm fastball that's what happens when
it gets hit
here's the 1-1 pitch that ball slug
pretty well deep to left that's a way
back and that ball is out of here
home run carlos santana
the royals have scored three in the
seventh and they have jumped out to a
5-1 lead
you want insurance runs
you got it instantly side armor from the
left side
lets him see the ball greatly and man
you could tell on contact how loud that
was pass out the earplugs
that ball was mashed
so first and third and one out instead
of an ending ending double play and then
whit is going to shoot it to right field
walsh makes the catch
the throw comes in late
dozier scores and the royals lead 6-1 in
the eighth inning
and here's tyler zuber making his season
debut the next one to boom is swung on
and missed
so down goes
for the third straight time swinging
[Music]
super is impressive he strikes out two
in his first game back
and the royals come back in the series
and they take two out of three
and the royals take a series from the
angels
for the first time in four years